Dave grass is one of the most
outstanding both intellectuals of modern
urban America as well as the most
insightful and creative practitioners
working with the private sector working
with foundations that who is putting
together best practices for the
enrichment and empowerment of her
innocence he has much to offer us and we
should be very grateful to have him here
as our first speaker in Arlen Heritage
course and I was told to speak to for 20
minutes to you and what I will do is
talk a little bit about the book and
talk a little bit about why I was
interested in writing this particular
kind of book and say a bit about
contemporary Harlem and how its evolved
and talk a little bit about some of the
resident perspectives that I encountered
as in doing this particular research
which you saw in listening to Harlem
listening to Harlem is an overview of
some of the recent changes in Harlem and
it is an analysis of urban economic and
Community Development and the ways in
which that kind of development actually
has an impact on communities and the way
in which communities particularly long
time residents experience these kinds of
changes and the ways in which they get
involved in the community to try to
ensure that the kinds of changes that
are taking place in their neighborhoods
are actually going to be of benefit to
them which i think is a critical part of
this particular overview and looking at
listening to Harlem over all my sins of
looking at the evolution of Harlem over
the last few decades is one that those
of us who were in New York see on a
regular basis change
you might be able to see almost before
your very eyes thinking about where
Harlem was in the middle 1980s to where
it is right now you see an area that is
relatively dramatically different when
people used to talk about Harlem in the
late 1970s and the early 1980s they
began to think of Harlem as a place
where they'd never want to go where
they'd want to retreat from which they'd
want to retreat and a place that they
considered scary a place that they
considered violent and of course all
along there have been residents living
in the community for generations there
were some residents who did leave Harlem
but there were many residents who didn't
what we began to see in the 1990s was a
shift in terms of the focus on Harlem
that we began to see people who in 1985
would have said no never I'll never live
in Harlem or no never I will never
invest in Harlem all of a sudden begin
to take interest and we began to see a
number of rapid changes in the way in
which this particular neighborhood has
changed it's very interesting when we
think about Harlem all urban
neighborhoods change in some way shape
or form over time and when we think of
the process of what's known as
gentrification we sometimes see rapid
change in urban neighborhoods but
imagining Harlem and its sheer size the
fact that it covers three city districts
the fact that it has a few hundred
thousand people as residents make it a
very unique kind of place in terms of
urban change so to imagine the kind of
change we've been seeing in Harlem
happening over a short period of time
really speaks to a number of dynamics
and really suggests well what's the
impact of these kinds of changes who's
being affected by this and and daring to
as the question who truly benefits from
the kinds of changes that are taking
place in Harlem right now so when we
think of the Harlem of the mid-1990s up
to now we think of a Harlem where there
is increased interest there is increased
investment
and you can walk on 125th street and see
businesses that you would see from any
part of the country you could see them
on thirty-fourth Street you could see
them in a mall in some part of suburban
America whether it's old navy or any of
the kinds of stores you see along 125th
street and you see that kind of change
and one of the things I wanted to talk
about is the fact that when we think
about gentrification and those who have
analyzed gentrification we often look at
it and I think a relatively limited way
we often look at it in terms of people
changes in demographics and in terms of
real estate changes in the prices of
real estate now the very concept of
gentrification does suggest a change in
people the very notion suggests that as
a neighborhood gentrified you have a
replacement of an old population with a
new population that would be seen as a
quote unquote gentry but what I've
noticed in urban development in quote
unquote gentrifying neighborhoods all
over the country as well as in Harlem is
that there are other dimensions that are
at work I think in addition to changes
in people and changes in real estate we
also see changes in business and also
see changes in culture listening to
Harlem began as a project that was going
to look specifically at business
community relations in Harlem and it
grew to a more comprehensive view of the
overall changes in the neighborhood and
tried to take account of these key four
categories in which there are
significant dynamics taking place and so
when we think about real estate of
course this comes to mind for those who
have tried to find an apartment in
Harlem those who have tried to purchase
property in Harlem in terms of
residential real estate we know the
changes are dramatic there dramatic in
new york city as a whole and indeed that
has had an effect on what has taken
place in harlem but when you think about
the fact that one could have purchased a
shell of a building which could be a
brown
stone that isn't developed in any way
just its overall structure no windows
nothing else something like that even 10
years ago might have gone for a few
hundred thousand dollars which now would
go over go for over a million dollars
when we think about a rental housing
market we're talking about double triple
quadruple in some instances the rate of
change and when we think about Manhattan
as a whole we're talking about fifteen
percent every single year in terms of
the value of an apartment and those
rates are higher in terms of the changes
in Harlem so we're talking about a
rapidly changing economic environment as
far as real estate is concerned and
another critical piece that often gets
overlooked in gentrification is that we
see a critical change in commercial real
estate as well which i think is one of
the more salient and interesting aspects
of the changes that we're seeing right
at this very moment in Harlem which we
can talk about and and talking in terms
of that business dimension that's
critical as well and maybe in Harlem and
make it might be more critical than in
some other urban neighborhoods because
Harlem is very much both commercial and
residential heavily residential but it
does have commercial thoroughfares and
anytime you think about a neighborhood
there are services in that neighborhood
for that community and those services
are oftentimes in some way shape or form
organized and coordinated by local
businesses and they could be for-profit
businesses and they could also be non
profit businesses which is another area
that is often overlooked when we talk
about neighborhood change but thinking
about what has happened from a business
perspective Harlem has historically been
a place for small businesses when we
think in terms of the last few decades
we haven't thought about major
multinational retail establishments
being situated in Harlem but we had an
empowerment zone which in the middle
1990s brought new resources to Harlem
and in terms of developing an
application for the empowerment zone the
intent was to bring jobs to the
community so in bringing
jobs to the community the expectation
was that if you brought larger retail
establishments they would bring multiple
jobs right so indeed many of those
larger retail establishments are in
Harlem right now but part of the
question is what kind of jobs did they
bring and to what degree have those jobs
actually brought major economic
advantages to the neighborhood now
certainly there are certain kinds of
resources that people might not have
been able to access that are now in the
neighborhood because of some of these
new retail establishments but at the
same time we have seen a situation where
many of the historic small businesses
are no longer able to exist in Harlem
because of increased prices we do see
new small businesses coming into Harlem
as well and new small businesses which
in some ways actually are focused a bit
more on a different kind of a clientele
which gets to the people dimension and
anytime we talk about urban development
and urban change and gentrification we
always have to look at the concept of
people and often when those who are
thinking about strategies for improving
urban communities we always have to
raise the dual question of people and
place do we create development
initiatives that are for the existing
people and for the place or do we create
development initiatives that are for the
place and not for the existing people
and that has been one of the great
tensions and the great ironies when
people have talked about urban
development because indeed many of the
longtime residents in Harlem have wanted
to see changes in the neighborhood have
wanted to have fresh produce in grocery
stores have wanted to have access to
ATMs to bank machines have wanted to
have taxi cabs come into the
neighborhood there are many services
that are Nyssa Arnett on necessities
that have not been accessible to
longtime residents however as some of
the new resources have come into
neighborhood there has been some sense
among residents that maybe these new
resources are not for the longtime
residents but for the residents to come
and indeed as you could see and
listening to Harlem and as you can find
in any demographic data on Harlem that
there is a gradual change in terms of
the demographics of the community
racially economically in terms of
homeowners in terms of whites moving
into Harlem and indefinitely in terms of
a class dimension and that's something
that people often remind me of that some
of the and many of the new residents to
Harlem happen to be of African descent
but may be of a different class than
people who have been there for a long
time and all of these factors create
some interesting dynamics and I also
think a cultural dimension is very
important to take into account when we
think about urban change and of course
as you will hear throughout this course
the reality is that Harlem plays a very
unique cultural role not only in the
United States not only among
african-americans but in the world and
among people of African descent all over
the world it has symbolically been in
some way shape or form synonymous with
the progress of people of African
descent with the culture of people of
African descent and so there is a
uniqueness about Harlem and is that very
uniqueness which has attracted people to
the neighborhood from all over the world
over the years and so part of the
question is the degree to which the
development that's happening in Harlem
now is actually in some way shape or
form upholding some of the culture that
has existed the reality is that change
is going to happen everyone has to be
prepared for change in some shape or
form and it's important to balance this
conversation and say yeah obviously all
neighborhoods evolve all neighborhoods
change but the question remains in terms
of what kind of change so one of the
things I sought to find out is the
degree to which some longtime residents
actually experience the
kinds of changes that have been
happening in the neighborhood what's
benefiting them what's challenging to
them and what was very interesting is
that there was indeed a very balanced
view and as you can see in listening to
Harlem one resident to the next to the
next to the next does not think the same
way we're not talking about a uniform
perspective on what's right and wrong
about changes in the neighborhood
however it did become clear that the
kinds of things that many of the longer
time residents do like about the
neighborhood on the fact that there are
some of those resources in place that
weren't there before there is a level of
access that people might not have had
before people don't have to shop
downtown get on the subway bring their
groceries back home and they can do it
right in their neighborhood there are
some basic aspects of subsistence and
everyday living that have been enhanced
by a lot of the changes that have taken
place in the neighborhood and the fact
that there is a greater attention to the
neighborhood there there may be a level
of feeling of safety in the community
that people might not have had before
and even in terms of changing the
demographics of the neighborhood to have
a community where there is a certain
degree of mixed income means that people
who are living in impoverished
situations are not necessarily isolated
and that people are in in some way
integrated with those who have greater
resources so the kinds of changes that
take place in these kinds of urban
environments we have a mixing of people
from different economic and racial
backgrounds does have its benefits to a
certain degree but I think there is a
certain insecurity about where the
changes are going I think there is a
certain insecurity about what kinds of
influence that people can have over the
changes in the neighborhood I thought
the first thing that people were going
to say was the the prices going up
that's the thing that bothers people the
most and what became very striking to me
is that was was very much on people's
mind was the issue of part two
the patient the degree to which longtime
residents felt they had a say in the
kinds of changes that have been taking
place in their neighborhood and part of
the irony of some of the changes that
have taken place in Harlem is that it
was the resident organizing on blocks
that made a lot of the blocks in Harlem
safer and it was some of that resident
resident organizing that made those
blocks more palatable to people from the
outside and so there is a sense that
people feel they toughed it out they
spent a lot of time in the neighborhood
they didn't move out when a lot of
people were moving out and now there's a
situation where people may or may not be
able to afford to stay in the
neighborhood now when we think about
some of the units of real estate in
terms of those smaller units in in New
York City those smaller apartment
complexes that may have six or fewer
units those units are very much up to
the whim of the owner so if there's a
change in ownership in those residential
units it's up to the owner to decide
whether or not residents day so there is
rent control and rent stabilization in
New York but it doesn't apply to all
types of buildings so there are several
buildings in Harlem where there is
extreme vulnerability to residents many
of the types of people who want to move
into harlem now are much more likely to
want to make those kinds of apartment
complexes single-family homes
single-family homes with one tenant or
single-family homes all together so
there are lots of complicated dynamics
that that take place and even for those
who own which is very interesting
speaking to some of the longtime owners
in the community if they sell could they
remain in the neighborhood if they
wanted to purchase something else in the
neighborhood at the new prices and that
was a question for lots of people so you
have this sense of choice and I think
when we talk about empowerment of
communities when we talk about
empowerment of communities that may not
have historically had a great deal of
access to resources
very important to look at issues of
choice and I think that while the
demographics that some might see in
Harlem have not demonstrated a radical
change in terms of the numbers of people
who've come in in a numbers of people
who've left it does suggest that over
time we could begin to see something
that approaches radical change because
of the limited choices that a lot of
longtime residents have but overall as I
mentioned one of the things that struck
me was the degree to which many longtime
residents felt that they really wanted
to have more of a say in what goes on in
the neighborhood and felt as if their
voices were not heard and that there
were not opportunities for them to
engage and not opportunities for them to
shape where things would go from there
and with that I will stop as I have
taken my time and then take some of your
questions yes
definitely different opinions but if you
receive questions okay we're okay you
want to say the question again so I can
then say it again
of those of those community members who
felt their voices haven't been heard
over time in Harlem what are some of
their ideas about changes in the
neighborhood is there a consistent
thinking among them and I think the
consistency more lies in the very
process of involvement and people not
necessarily sure which I think speaks to
another dimension looking forward not
necessarily feeling sure they understood
where they could participate and how
they could participate and how they
could have an influence outside of what
goes on there on their own block so
there is a sense of civic engagement
there's a question around civic
engagement that I think is important
here and any time we see a neighborhood
that is undergoing the kind of change
that we're seeing in Harlem you can see
the value of having organized
communities not to say that communities
aren't organized in Harlem but the
reality is it's such a vast neighborhood
and the various spheres of change in
terms of how the neighborhood is
affected are in so many different
environments now there was a process
around the empowerment zone and that
process did involve community residents
and this is something that is important
to take into account but the reality is
which community residents got to be at
that table and how do you make those
kinds of decisions so I did speak to
some residents who were actually
involved in that process as well as some
who weren't and so some who were
involved felt to a certain degree that
they were glad to be involved and they
were glad to have been asked but even
they felt that in the end it was not
necessarily their voices that were going
to make final major decisions it was
going to be voices that were more at the
level of Congress more at the level of
businesses and the in terms of large
corporations
there is a varied sent to a certain
degree of opinion but there's also
varied experience among some of the
residents in terms of the degree to
which they've been involved but what I
tried to do also in listening to Harlem
was to talk a little bit about some of
the various kinds of suggestions that
residents and community based
organizations had in terms of trying to
be involved in changing the neighborhood
and trying to which i think is an
important point when we do have
situations where new rhesus resources
are coming into neighborhoods that have
experienced a history of disinvestment
how do the existing residents in that
community in those kinds of communities
take advantage of the resources that are
coming in so one of the suggestions that
came out was the degree to which
residents could actually sit down with
some of the corporations that have an
interest in coming into the community
and talk to them about how to come to
mutually beneficial conclusions about
bringing certain kinds of resources to
the community but also being involved in
different ways in the community there
was a sense that so much of the change
that's been going on has been focused on
ok we're going to develop real estate
we're going to bring in new businesses
we're going to bring jobs but a lot of
the residents want people to do things
about the local schools they want people
to do things that are more focused on
the social infrastructure of the
community and there's a feeling that
some of that aspect of what's been going
on is left out which then contributes to
the sense that the changes that are
going on in the neighborhood are not as
much about the priorities of the
existing residents but more about the
place and about the residents to come
there are many hands here and I don't
know how to be fair yes we'll go up
front
existing
mm-hmm what is the feedback from
community-based organizations like the
Harlem Children's Zone about some of the
changes that are going on in the
neighborhood and you will see in
listening to Harlem that there is some
featuring of some of the work of
different community organizations the
Harlem congregation's for Community
Improvement Harlem Children's Zone the
Harlem Children's Zone has a an
initiative called community pride which
is featured in the book and it was very
intriguing to me to see this because
what community pride had done and they
are they provide a forum for local
residents that are in that particular
zone that the Harlem Children's Zone has
carved out in the neighborhood to talk
about issues that are affecting the
neighborhood and to try to
collaboratively develop problem-solving
strategies one of the strategies that
they developed was to take advantage of
an old law that was never overturned
which was designed to allow people to
take over city-owned buildings for very
low rates and turn them into limited
equity cooperatives and what they were
able to do was get quite a number of
residents in that local community to
actually own apartments in these
cooperatives that were city-owned
buildings that during the 1970s and
remember the evolution during the 1970s
and the 1980s people wanted to leave
Harlem people wanted to get out of
Harlem people who own businesses wanted
to burn their businesses and get
insurance
people wanted to leave so they develop
policy incentives to get people to stay
they wanted to encourage people to
develop these buildings and get people
to live in them so they wouldn't be
abandoned so they wouldn't become crack
houses so they wouldn't become all of
these other things and that this law was
still on the books and the Harlem
Children's Zone in the community pride
initiative took advantage of that and
many of the other organizations that
focus on community and housing
development in the neighborhood took
advantage of some of those incentives
for affordable housing development as
well and part of the challenge you will
see in contemporary Harlem very very
contemporary Harlem is that many of
those organizations that have been doing
work like that have found themselves in
an environment where there are dried up
incentives to develop affordable housing
much of the focus on housing development
in Harlem right now is more on luxury
housing more on new condo developments
and in that very neighborhood with the
Harlem Children's Zone works you will
see more activity than in other parts of
Harlem in terms of some of the new
buildings going up it's a very it's very
evident as you walk the streets in that
particular part of town thank you yes
together about the stability and
durability of this trajectory of change
of like gentrification capital and
resources coming in demographic change
because I mean like I was talking
somebody like this recent like housing
downturn I mean I don't know the
specifics of it but like is there a
sense that it's just going to keep
coming in and people are going to keep
communities are going to keep changing
worker then something turn around and
there's disinvestment what is the sense
of the cycle of change around housing
housing values in communities and in
these kinds of gentrifying situations is
this something that is going to pass and
the real estate values will then go down
and then the neighborhood will stabilize
again in terms of the rates of housing
prices that's always possible and there
even today there are questions about the
degree of building and the degree to
which some of those new condo
establishments are going to be sold
there are some of those buildings that
are not sold out so even now you can see
some of those kinds of changes this is
housing is always cyclical in that sense
and then you have to ask the question
about the degree to which in certain
markets you don't see the downturns so
if we look at the downturns that are
going on all over the country right now
there are certain parts of the country
where you're not seeing a downturn where
you're seeing stabilization in terms of
increases in prizing of housing and one
of those areas is Manhattan right so
Harlem has always been Harlem and
Manhattan has been south of Harlem but
is there a Manhattan ization of Harlem
to the point where
them is now a part of that Manhattan
exception and those rates will stay at a
very high level you certainly the rates
of increase in housing prices in Harlem
are affected and have been affected by
the rates of increases in prices in
housing all over this region so when
there are residents talking about those
who have left Harlem as a result of
increases in pricing I asked where did
they go and the answers were rarely just
down the street were rarely 23 miles
away were often Virginia North Carolina
South Jersey Philadelphia it's a much
broader range so one of the real
interesting realities of the development
around Manhattan and around New York
City is that the desire to be in New
York City and the new york city
metropolitan area is so high that people
are commuting into New York City from
Philadelphia I was told that was one of
the recent trends I know there was a
straight line yes privilege to questions
about five years ago a administrator in
Columbia I won't say his name but he's
very proud he's no longer in that
position said to me that the Harlem
that's in your imagination you know the
Harlem Renaissance the Harlem of the
Savoy Ballroom of the 40s the Harlem of
the cultural the black arts movement of
the 60s no longer exists and definitely
will not exist in the next 20 years
and if you think about it at the
beginning of the century the 20th
century Harlem was overwhelmingly either
ethnically jewish you had Irish some
Germans and Italians and East Harlem was
overwhelmingly Italian and to some
extent Jewish and remain that until the
Puerto Ricans began to move in later in
the 20th century but there was a time
when Harlem was overwhelmingly white it
only became overwhelmingly black in the
1920s and 30s but even then it had
substantial white population can you
envision a time in the future when
blacks represent a minority of the
population of Arlen due to the trends of
gentrification that's kind of question
one when will Harlem seems to be black
to put it mildly yes so they take that
mountain okay manhattanville all right
about three weeks ago community district
4 10 9 9 is West not okay a meeting to
discuss that Hassinger I understand it
was a lively affair and they voted down
Colombia's proposal I wondered if you
could talk about the evolution
your take on it and if you were talking
to president Bollinger what would you
say to him about it mm-hmm okay first
question when will Harlem cease to be
black next question what is my
perspective on manhattanville and
Columbia's intentions in that particular
part of West Harlem I'll take the
manhattanville first you should know
that a lot of my work has had to do with
the role of universities in their
surrounding communities my first book
beyond the campus is about that very
topic and I do speak quite frequently on
that particular issue so it is an issue
that is very close to my heart and I
have some general ideas about what I
perceive to be promising practices let's
say in terms of university community
partnerships I think successful
university community partnerships very
much do as I was mentioning about the
residents perspective in terms of
working with corporations successful
university community partnerships start
with communication they start with
communication with surrounding
stakeholders whether there are residents
whether they're local businesses local
community-based organizations local
government and the reason they should
start with partnership and communication
is because usually even in a very
contested space you can find some mutual
benefit out of those kinds of
negotiations so if columbia university
wants to develop the western swath of
land alongside the sent more central
part of harlem from the 120s to the 130s
which is known as manhattanville which
has historically been zoned as pretty
much an industrial area it's not
necessarily residue
Joe if columbia university wants to
develop in that area there are clearly
benefits to be had by columbia but there
could also be benefits to be had by the
community so my thinking on
manhattanville is that whatever happens
in that particular swath of land should
be mutually beneficial to both the
community and to columbia university the
way that conversation has evolved from
the point at which the manhattanville
plan was rolled out to now where there
is tension and as Professor marable
mentioned the community board has struck
down the proposal there were dimensions
of communication and partnership that
did not take place in the way that I
think effective university community
partnerships unfold and the first
challenge was the degree to which the
plans were rolled out so the plans were
presented and then defended as opposed
to presented as an idea that may be
beneficial both to the community and the
university and one that would be
finalized out of dialogue in partnership
what has happened over time is that when
the plan was rolled out there was
response from the community there was a
fair amount of negative response from
the community and as was mentioned in
terms of the book and in terms of how
residents have been feeling about
changes in Harlem people want to be
involved people want to participate
people want to be asked what would be
good for the very neighborhood in which
they are living and so ultimately the
plan was defended and there was a lot of
debate and then ultimately it was
concluded that what was needed was a
community benefits agreement the
community benefits agreement to
determine
potential mutual benefit between the
development and the community that is
something that could have happened from
the very beginning in my sense of that
particular process so that's that answer
the other answer in terms of can Harlem
will Harlem cease to be black as a
geographical space Harlem has had
different demographics over the years
and clearly from throughout the 20th
century although Harlem had been black
through most of the twenty 20th century
there was always a sense that Harlem was
a quote-unquote gateway that Harlem was
prime real estate prime real estate
because it had access to downtown
Manhattan access to the rest of the
country going west New Jersey and
otherwise access on the east side going
out to the airports going out to Long
Island out to Queens and access to the
north going into the bronson into the
suburbs very few places in manhattan no
other place in Manhattan has that kind
of access so Harlem as a geographical
space was always thought of as strategic
and always thought of as a place that
needed to be developed before Harlem
became black there was over anticipation
in terms of what could happen in Harlem
and Harlem being envisioned as a suburb
for a lot of white ethnics and there was
over building and they couldn't fill all
of those units of housing and there was
anticipation about the building of the
inner inner rapid transit IRT as we know
it and when that didn't happen people
began to leave and ultimately they were
okay we can allow some of you all to
come in but we're going to charge you
higher rates to come in at that and then
ultimately Harlem became black so I
don't think there's any guarantee that
that Geographic
space will always remain black it is a
prawn is prime real estate there are
significant interests in that particular
area so part of the question is the
degree to which preservation is a part
of the agenda in terms of the long-term
development of Harlem and I think it is
to the strategic advantage of Harlem as
a neighborhood and many of those who
live there to continue to take advantage
of the cultural history and the
significance of Harlem when you think
about tourists I mentioned in listening
to Harlem that Harlem has been often the
second and sometimes the first choice
among tourists to visit particularly
among tourists from other parts of the
world particularly among tourists from
places like Japan and Germany and people
want to go to Harlem and visit Harlem
not just because it happens to be in
manhattan not just because it happens to
be a convenient geographic space they
want to go to Harlem to see the churches
they want to see the history they want
to go to the Apollo they know the
history they want to hear jazz there was
a sense that there are unique aspects of
Harlem that are attractive so on the one
hand yeah it could change but on the
other hand I think it's to the strategic
advantage of the neighborhood and those
who have interests in the neighborhood
to preserve the culture and the heavy
emphasis on african-american history and
the significance of Harlem to people of
African descent worldwide
mm-hmm well I have really biased this
side of the room so I'm going to take
you how feasible do you think is to to
preserve the ESS apartment culture and
social and changing it that sounds
previously
what factors do you think are going to
be required in order to maintain
mm-hmm is it feasible to preserve
Harlem's culture and people and those
things we love about Harlem well I do
think it's feasible I think it's
definitely feasible I first of all some
of the new establishment that have come
into Harlem have not necessarily focused
on things other than black culture right
so there has been an interest among
those who are moving into Harlem and
some of the businesses that have come to
harlem in preserving that culture so I
think the continuation of that will be
very important I also think an
understanding of that value the value as
I just mentioned that can be gained by
preserving that culture especially
thinking of the the attraction the
generation of tourist dollars the
generation of activity can be very
significant there is a lot of cultural
expression in Harlem that can be taken
advantage of I was recently working with
the urban design lab here at Columbia
and 125th Street business improvement
district which has been talking about
making 125th Street a contiguous
cultural corridor and a part of that
concept is to provide more affordable
spaces for community-based organizations
that are focused on preserving the
history and culture of harlem on 125th
Street in order to bring a certain
unique type of life and activity on that
street and that could be a significant
revenue generator a lot of neighborhoods
around the country and world have used
and leveraged the cultural history of a
neighborhood to its long-term economic
advantage of by focusing on history by
developing cultural institutions by
developing museums and the like
so there are definitely opportunities to
rap in culture in the ongoing economic
and community development of Harlem all
right let's give up dr. Rast a big round